The answer is, you can't construct an interface type. We know this can't be the
answer because we have assigned objects of certain classes to variables of
interface types. In the example before this, you saw code that created new dogs
and then put them in drawable variable or added them to lists of drawable
items. So this statement is false. This statement is true, but doesn't apply in
this case. I can only put an object into a variable with an interface type if
the object is of a class that implements the interface. Like in this case. But
if the dog class didn't implement the drawable interface, I wouldn't be able to
do this. If you're not quite sure why you can't construct an interface type,
let's look at the code. This is the code for a dog. It has all of the
information on how to move and how to draw. The drawable interface has almost
no information at all. If you tried to make a new drawable, it would know that
it should know how to draw. But wouldn't know how to draw. That's why Java
won't let you construct a drawable.